[Musique]
sharif
excusez moi je vous ai mouillé
[Musique]
amos indiqué ce dernier
je suis désolé alex mais c'est fini qui
va à la chasse perd sa place qui te sens
comment faut là on fera de la maison la
piscine
c'est la première fois que je suis au
chômage taqwa 50 60 dont beaucoup moins
battu fait plus
sap a de la famille dans le coin ah ben
je voulais voir ma soeur et ma petite
nièce ego tu sais je sais parler tandis
qu'alex feignant moche et débile oui
c'est lui les champions de voir bondir
la règle à la maison c'est du salut tu
nettoies j'évoque on peut faire ça on
peut pas faire
voilà ce que tu vas faire c'est une âme
une étoile eva elle sait même pas si tu
vas te trouver une nouvelle fois plus
riche et plus vieilles villes de nitra
tournage tu peux plus te lancer dans une
aventure trop longue
c'est qu'ils savent armand est parfaite
et un grand-papa hirsch il est mort l'an
dernier
excellente nouvelle si je te disais
clairement savoir tu peux obtenir ce que
tu veux on commence quand leçon numéro
un tout est dans le regard accroche bien
le regarder tu apprends accroche a crush
crush tu as décroché savoir ce que tu
apprends monfils dernière leçon du jour
la démarche ouest et fès et un petit
bout par petit bout et c'est plus les
années passent
puis celle de la fraîcheur
[Musique]
c'est de la merde
je m'en viens avec ma foi bondir on a
juste fait un tout petit tour